in this situation i might just grab both
of my wrists
i'm going to drive those arms right at
him like a cocky
hole and split the two so one hand is
going
low and one hand is going high tension
literally means heavier so 10 is high
and chi is earth low so i split the two
like this
this compromises balance and then i step
through
one of the big problems people have with
this technique is they tend to spread
their arms wide as they come through
if i enter with really wide arms you can
see i take nothing from mike
i want my arms to stay right in front of
my body you can see i have a big effect
on my here
as his arm split and i begin to break
his balance i set my other leg behind
him to keep him from stepping and bring
him down
one more time to speak
rio de doro